all right let's do a little um let's do
almost like a history lesson type
segment here i have an example for you
today of something that the modern
republican party is now regularly
engaging in that is indistinguishable
from standard historical fascist
propaganda it checks all the boxes today
we're going to be comparing it
specifically to
italian fascist propaganda during and in
the pre-mussolini era it'll all make
sense in a moment come along for the
ride we will start with radical
pro-trump republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green's new political
advertisement apparently she's running
in 2022 we were we've been wondering how
many of these trumpets will run in 2022
if they run how many of them are going
to win it's going to be a big piece of
influencing whether or not donald trump
runs in 2024.
marjorie taylor green in her new ad says
i guess
if you reelect her she's going to blow
away the democrats socialist agenda
and then in the video she actually blows
up a car a prius
with socialism on it with a 50-cal rifle
that she is also auctioning off
uh for people who contribute to her
campaign like ev every aspect of this is
just a dystopian fascist propaganda
piece let's take a look at it and then
um we are going to discuss okay so
here's the ad see pelosi is sneaking the
green new deal into the 3.5 trillion
dollar budget and in 2022 i'm going to
blow away the democrats socialist agenda
[Music]
yeah so the website she refers to is is
greengun.com
this is straight up fascist propaganda
and it's an it's potentially an
incitement to violence because she's
normalizing
shooting socialist priuses right i mean
it's it's not even an analogy she's
shooting a socialist prius in the car so
we have a ton of examples of fascist
propaganda this is just another example
when you look for examples of the
propaganda of fascist italy leading up
to and during the mussolini era
it's this type of stuff i'm going to
tell you the themes of this is now these
are the themes of italian fascist
propaganda
very well known historically and look at
how much it applies to marjory taylor
green number one personality cults
around individuals this is not marjorie
taylor green talking about policy
this is marjorie taylor greene building
a cult of personality around her
as a socialist
gun toter who blows up
socialist priuses right that's what it
is
action over talk as a form of politics
was a theme of italian fascist
propaganda marjorie taylor green
shooting a gun at a socialist car she's
not talking about issues she's not
talking about solving problems like an
adult she's using action over talk as
the default of politics um from okay so
now this one because marjorie taylor
green is a woman we have to think a
little bit differently about this one
but for mussolini and italian fascism
fertility and the strength of men was a
big thing this is kind of like a female
version of it although there's not as
direct of an analogy of marjorie taylor
green
uh uh
appearing to be
more likely to bear children on the
basis of shooting guns but there's also
a bit of a masculinization of marjorie
taylor green so so maybe it does
actually apply that's another one
attacking foreign culture
in italy it was americanism that was
attacked
french and russian literature were
attacked etc
in this case with marjorie taylor green
it's the pseudo-foreign culture of
american socialists they're not
foreigners but the idea is they aren't
like us they're not really americans in
the mold that we believe americans
should exist so very similar
and then of course italian fascist
propaganda was anti-democratic and it
was anti-small l liberalism
shooting your political opponents is not
democratic this is again about firearms
as solutions
the use of slogans to cover
the violence of what you propose okay
that was a common thing at the eight
second mark in this video which i will
pull up for you it says in 2022 i'm
going to blow away the democrats
socialist agenda
and notice she blows up a toyota prius a
sort of emblem of what they don't like
prius you know one of the first hybrid
vehicles now available as a plug-in car
even that detail is rev relevant to the
fascistic nature of the propaganda it's
a fight for foss or fossil fuels we're
not no silly hybrids or electric cars
now that's the analysis with fascist
propaganda from italy um
just you know you could you could do it
with something else altogether but we've
just picked that
and our friend and fellow argentinian
federico finkelstein
who is an expert on fascism actually
tweeted in response to this video
fascist propaganda 101
we have to be calling this for what it
is
lots of politicians
blowing things up
taliban style
to make political points about how bad
liberals are and how the left has to be
punished and meanwhile if you propose
like a child tax credit
that's called socialist by these very
same people they're disseminating actual
fascistic propaganda but if you want
like health care for people or a child
tax credit or enhanced unemployment then
you are you are called a socialist it's
really dangerous stuff and unfortunately
if it's not uh sort of rooted out um
it's going to increasingly become more
and more common that we see it why
because they've abandoned policy
altogether notice that there's no policy
there there's no there's no po it's just
we're gonna block we're gonna blow away
the socialists and block nancy how does
she pronounce it pelosi
um etc they're going to keep doing this
type of stuff unless somebody somebody
or something stops them or unless it
loses them elections because they've
given up on policy years ago we've
talked about that before